When using Sequencer to create linear content, you must fully understand what the Camera
Cuts track is being utilized for, along with comprehending the idea of using nested level
sequences.
In a nutshell, the Camera Cuts track is responsible for binding specific cameras to the level
sequence so Unreal knows which camera to render.
Level sequences that are used as shots are brought into the parent level sequence via
the Shot track, and each shot must have its own dedicated camera and camera cuts track.
As you build your parent or master level sequence, Sequencer takes on its non-linear
editor role to allow you to move your shots into any order you see fit.
In our demo, we'll be recreating an even simpler three shot sequence that leverages these concepts.
Please understand that there are multiple ways to go about this process.
The style in which you build your shots will ultimately be what works best for you.
Anytime you start a new project, its success or failure largely depends upon how organized
you are.
Sequencer is no different.
To start, let's make sure you have the 105.02 map properly loaded.
The level will be located in the Course Maps folder within the Courses folder.
Find the 105.02 level file and double click on it to load it.
This is your level.
Next you'll need to make your own working directory.
To do this, navigate to the Courses folder and then open the SEQ 105.02 folder.
In there you'll find the Course Topics folder.
Open that and proceed on to the Shot Creation folder and finally create your own folder.
Since there is an existing Multi Shot EX folder, call your folder something else in order
to store your files in it.
Double click on the folder and it will immediately open.
Now you're going to need a level sequence.
Inside your Multi Shot EX folder, right click and go to the Cinematics pop up contextual
menu to create a level sequence.
Call this SEQ underscore cine underscore EX.
This is ultimately going to be your parent or master level sequence.
Create three folders and name them cinexshot1, cinexshot2, and cinexshot3.
These folders will hold the necessary level sequences for your shots.
It's best to break out shots into separate folders for the sake of keeping things organized.
Next enter the folder for your first shot.
Create a level sequence and name it ms underscore ex underscore shot1.
This is your first shot.
Don't create extra shots yet though.
We'll save that for another step.
Once you've created your shot, double click on the icon and open Sequencer.
Once your shot is open, you'll need to create a new cine camera.
Use the create camera button in the sequencer toolbar to add a spawnable camera.
This will also generate a camera cuts track.
Rename the camera cinecam underscore 01 underscore shot1.
You can pilot the camera by pressing the camera pilot button.
It will turn blue when it's active.
Next you'll need to add an actor to sequencer.
Since the original 105.02 map doesn't include an SK mannequin in the level, we must find
one and place one there.
Go to the content browser and navigate to the assets folder.
Open it and then continue to the mannequin folder.
Inside you'll find the character and mesh folders.
You'll want the SK mannequin mesh in the mesh folder.
Click and drag this into your level.
Return to sequencer and with mani selected click the plus add button.
Go to add actor to sequencer and then choose add SK mannequin.
Once in sequencer, right click over mani in sequencer's outliner and convert the selected
binding to spawnable.
Now it's time to add some animation to our actor.
Since we'll be using animation sequences rather than directly keyframing mani's control rig
itself, we must remove or mute the control rig to allow the animation sequence to function.
Select the control rig and delete it.
Don't worry, you can always get it back later.
Now to get your animation on your actor, click the plus button for mani in the animation
track.
This will bring up a menu for you to choose an animation sequence.
Search for mani underscore anim underscore track and add it to sequencer.
Once loaded, make sure the sequence starts at frame zero.
Next we must adjust our actor's position, animate the camera and modify our shot's duration.
Whenever you add an animation sequence to an actor, please be aware that the animation
data might move your character to a different location.
If you noticed, by adding the mani anim track to mani, he's moved way past the scene where
we're filming.
This is because the animation sequence's animation was offset from zero zero zero when
it was exported.
To correct for this, all we have to do is zero out mani's transformations and he should
pop into place.
If you want him precisely in front of the sign, move him plus 50 units on the y axis.
Next we'll need to reposition the camera.
Click on the camera pilot button so you can see what the camera is seeing or if you prefer,
you can switch over to a two pane window layout and drag the camera into position.
If you're feeling adventurous, you can animate the camera by setting a few keyframes to push
in or boom up.
Finally, we must trim down the first shot to approximately 105 frames.
Move your time marker into position and press the right bracket key.
This will create an out point for your level sequence while the in point will remain at
zero.
Please realize that some studios will choose to start their sequences and shots at frame
one thousand one rather than at zero.
It's easier to leverage warm up frames and back time the shot if necessary.
But for now, zero is fine.
Finally, make sure that the camera cuts track runs the length of the entire shot.
If necessary, adjust its in and out points accordingly.
Our next step is to create our second shot, but we're going to do something a little different.
Instead of creating everything again from scratch, we're going to duplicate shot one
and use it as the basis for our next shot.
Once duplicated, rename it properly to shot two and move it to the appropriate shot folder.
Now that we have our second shot created, we'll need to modify our camera's position
and alter the animation track accordingly.
Delete any existing keyframes you might have created from shot one and move the camera
into a new position.
Secondly we're going to have to adjust and reposition the animation track for shot two's
performance by sliding the action we want towards frame zero.
Once you've retimed the animation track, be sure to adjust the camera cuts track and
the sequences out point accordingly.
For shot three, repeat steps six through eight, or if you'd like, you can just right-click
over the shot in Sequencer to duplicate and save your shot to the appropriate folder.
If you wish to explore different camera placements for shot three, you can either duplicate the
shot as an alternate take and manually replace it in your edit, or utilize Sequencer's take
system once you're in the level sequence with shots.
Now it's time to put everything together.
Go to your level sequence with shots and add a shot track.
This will allow you to bring your shots into Sequencer.
Place them in the appropriate order and adjust your level sequence with shots out point as
necessary.
Don't forget to add your duplicated third shot to the sequence, especially if you've
made some changes.
Click on the shot track's camera icon to review the sequence when you press play.
If you need to trim your shots to improve continuity, feel free to do so.
Once your shots are in the shot track, you can utilize Sequencer's take system to right-click
over the shot and create a new take.
This will also duplicate the shot and make it accessible in the take systems menu.
Once you make the shift, you can alter the take however you wish.
If you don't like it, you can always switch back to take one.
What I've just presented to you is just the beginning.
There are so many different ways shots can be constructed and modified.
You could leverage a subscene track for Manny's animation, or you can alter camera settings,
add some depth of field, or read time shots using various time remapping tools.
The options are up to you.
If you're curious about subscene tracks, the original SEQ Multi-Shot EX level sequence
includes the usage of a subscene track for your review.
Take a look and see how it might change your shot setup.
Now let's move on to some final recommendations.